Question on homework autograder about whether or not it parses like feedback on that.
Oh, to get more feedback? Yeah. This is a good question.
For the quizzes in lecture you get immediate feedback, and we think that's useful.
For the homeworks, you don't get any feedback until after the deadline
This is something we're thinking about how to provide some feedback on the homeworks
but still make them different from the quizzes in lecture.
You're getting some feedback but not getting the answer until after the deadline.
Until we have something like that in place, though, it's important that--
I've seen a lot of people that edit it in an external editor,
and then they paste it into our programming environment.
It can mess with the formatting, and Python is one of those languages where formatting matters.
Right. It's a good idea to run your code when you submit the homework to see the output.
I got three questions wrong in homework 2 for not doing that.
It's a good idea for everyone.
It's good the grading policy drops one homework. >>Yeah. You're going to need that one.
I think I'll do a canned exam, but we'll see.
So we have are you enjoying teaching a massive online open course?
Okay. So Michelle is asking if it's my first experience in a MOOC. It is my first experience in a MOOC.
The largest course I taught before this one had about 100 students, less than 100 students in it.
It was for CS? >>It was actually the data structures and data representation class.
The intro CS course that I teach at UVA last semester had 50 students in it.
That's been a typical size.
The first time I taught I had 9 students.
So the great thing in teaching small classes is getting to know all the students
and being able to understand at that level what everyone was doing,
but it's really terrific to be able to teach a class like this and have many thousands of students
from all around the world and the range of backgrounds.
There was a post in the forum about the background that several hundred of you posted in
and it's really interesting for me to see that and to see
how diverse the group of students that we have in the class is. >>It's inspiring.
It's inspiring and it is an opportunity that I think we're very humbled by and I'm humbled by
to have a chance to introduce this many people to computer science.
I hope we don't lose people, but I hope people are enjoying it and getting a lot out of it.
It's really gratifying to me to see what's happening and see how many people are contributing
in the forums and other ways to make the class better.
It is a really wonderful and amazing experience.
We have a question from Graham. How did you learn to firm program?
I think it is how did you both, so you can answer this as well.
I guess I'll go first, because I learned earlier since Peter was not alive when I learned to program.
I got started in programming when I was in elementary school. >>What?
My school got a Teletype computer.
This was a computer where it had paper and it was printing on it.
The year after that we got Apple 2s, and you had colors in screens.
But my first experience was with this Teletype computer that you called in "put a phone"
on coupler, and you could log into the computer--
Did you have to have a trial CD?
There was no trial CD. You just called in.
The cool thing about computing in those days was the code was written in a language called "Basic,"
and all the programs you could see what they were.
I started playing these games on the computer.
I wanted to do better in the games, because I was trying to win the games,
and you could type "list" and see all the code,
and it didn't make much sense to me at first,
but I started to look at it and try to understand what's going on and tried to change the code.
You were cheating? >>I was cheating in the games.
Once we got Apple 2s you could start to do cool things with colors and make pictures. It got really fun.
That's how I got started in programming.
I got started with little Legos.
There were these Lego sets--they're called Lego Mindstorm.
So basically it's a bunch of Legos with a couple motors,
and it's hooked up to a little processing unit that also powers the motors,
and you just hook it up to a computer.
The programming environment is block-based.
You just have a little Lego block that you do to do the command,
so it might be move forward for 30 seconds.
Things like a conditional that's like an if statement.
That's really the first thing I did programming.
I built a little robot that crawled around on my floor and would pick up "trash."
It couldn't pick up anything that heavy. Bits of paper.
Couple it tell whether something was trash or not? >>No, no.
It would basically patrol my floor until I threw things on the ground,
which was often, I suppose.
It's called the Roomba now.
Yeah, it's called a Roomba. They beat me to it. Dang.
I was always interesting in playing with the stuff--kind of building computers and things like that.
Then I went to a summer camp in middle school where we programmed in C,
and programming in C is not the funnest thing.
Yeah. Programming in Python is a lot more fun than the languages.
Yeah. You kids have it so easy.
When something breaks, it tells you what happened. Not in C.
Do we have any other questions?
Okay. We can go to the forums.
Do you want to pick one from the--
Let's see. We've got many pages of this.